il est des moments dans la vie politique
d'un pays ou des choix marqueront
durablement l'histoire pour les
décennies à venir aujourd'hui est un de
ces jours le projet de loi qui nous est
présenté marque le début de la
reconquête de notre souveraineté
énergétique ce texte est le premier
jalon dans chantier industriel qui
s'étalera sur plus d'un siècles et qui
doit conduire à atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 mesdames et messieurs
les députés rappelons-nous que la France
s'est engagée avec l'accord de Paris a
limité l'augmentation de la température
moyenne de la planète en dessous de 2
degrés par rapport au niveau
préindustriel nous devons tenir cet
engagement tant pour le bien de notre
planète que pour le bien des espèces
qu'il a peuple et il n'y a pas de
formule magique pour cela en accélérant
les procédures liées à la construction
de nouvelles installations nucléaires
cette loi permet de matérialiser
concrètement l'objectif de décarbonation
de notre mix énergétique
permettez-moi de préciser que le groupe
démocrate a bien entendu conscience des
difficultés et des interrogations
légitimes que pose le développement de
l'énergie nucléaire toutefois face aux
projections qui montrent une
augmentation de la consommation
d'énergie dans les années à venir face
aux différents scénarios proposés par
RTE qui démontre clairement que les
scénarios composés exclusivement
d'énergie renouvelables présentes bien
trop d'incertitudes quant à leur réel
achèvement il est de notre devoir de
trouver une solution pragmatique et
cette solution c'est le développement de
l'énergie nucléaire de manière raisonnée
encadrée et reposant sur une filière
d'excellence française qui a su faire
ses preuves au cours du temps qui plus
c'est la parfaite au nucléaire dans
notre mix énergétique a pour corollaire
la réduction de notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles et c'est là notre des
réel défi de mettre fin à l'usage des
énergies fossiles
le texte qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui
issu de la commission mixte paritaire et
telle qu'il a été voté mardi dernier par
le Sénat actualise la planification
énergétique simplifie les procédures
administratives relatives à la
construction des nouveaux réacteurs EPR
2 tout en prolongeant la durée de vie
des installations nucléaires existantes
s'il vous plaît permet également
d'améliorer la sûreté et la sécurité
nucléaire sur ce dernier volet le texte
final exclut toute fusion entre
l'Institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaires et l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire le groupe démocrate sur
ce sujet avec clairement fait part de
son extrême prudence et interrogation
quant à cette proposition le texte
prévoit ainsi dans la continuité de nos
débats que le gouvernement présentera
d'ici 6 mois en rapport évaluant les
besoins prévisionnels humains et
financiers nécessaires aux missions de
l'URSS de l'ASN et du Commissariat à
l'énergie atomique en définitive ce
texte nous les moyens de maîtriser notre
empreinte carbone au travers d'une
politique volontariste nous permettant
de respecter nos objectifs climatiques
grâce à ce texte nous simplifions les
procédures en dispensant les projets de
construction de réacteurs d'étapes
administratives multiples sans jamais
renier sur l'aspect sureté nous
permettons par exemple d'anticiper le
démarrage des travaux qui ne revêtent
aucun caractère sensible dès l'obtention
d'une autorisation environnementale nous
permettons une mise en compatibilité des
documents d'urbanisme par décret ce qui
accélère le développement des
infrastructures nucléaires et nous
remplissons l'objectif de ce texte qui
est que le temps de construction d'un
réacteur se rapproche au maximum du
temps industriel
le groupe démocrate tient un saluer le
travail réalisé dans le développement de
ce texte ambitieux conjoint avec les
sénateurs il est également la continuité
de l'action engagée depuis 2017 par le
gouvernement afin de se doter de tous
les outils pour remplir nos ambitions
climatiques pour conclure chers
collègues l'adoption de ce texte est un
signal fort envoyé à la filière du
nucléaire en France mais également au
monde avec lui nous affirmons notre
volonté de retrouver l'outil et la
culture industrielle nécessaire à la
réussite de grands projets nucléaires
conjointement avec la loi relative à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable ce texte nous
permet de nous diriger vers un modèle de
mix énergétique français pérenne qui
nous permettra d'atteindre nos objectifs
de neutralité carbone en 2050 pour ces
multiples raisons le groupe démocrate
vient votre a bien entendu en faveur de
ce texte et vous invite chers collègues
à faire de même je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie